all right let's go to catherine in
philadelphia hey catherine how's it
going
pretty good how are you good what's
going on
um so i have kind of a specific question
about taking some time off work to do
like a long
through hike onto the appalachian trail
okay well what's what's the situation
around it
um so i do have some money saved i'm i'm
on
i guess i'm technically on baby step
seven i don't have any kids or
a house um and then i have about 40 000
which is my emergency fund and then also
money that i would use
towards it um how much so i just kind of
was looking for some advice
how much extra do you have on top of
your emergency fund
all right that is the 40k is is
everything
okay and then my 401k i'm being 401k all
right sounds good what do you do
oh i'm an engineer okay how old are you
catherine
i'm 20 32 oh 32
yes okay all right um
should you take six months off to go
hiking
i i'm so excited about this answer i
can't even see straight because i feel
like there's going to be another
really good segment between me and you
because let me tell you catherine
ayo and i don't have the same answer on
this question i can just tell you
right now i can tell you right now go on
give her your answer
and then we'll go together but see
here's the thing we we might be
we might be on the same page okay let's
have it because she's debt-free
she doesn't have any you know she has a
fully funded emergency fund
here's where i have a question that will
determine my answer
uh catherine how much do you need for
six months to live like how much how
much will you have to spend
um on your bills back at home and to
survive how much money will you need
uh probably 8k and that's probably
overestimating
so about ten thousand dollars worst case
absolute worst case scenario
yeah that leaves you thirty thousand
dollars in your bank account
yes at thirty something how much do you
have in your retirement account right
now
a hundred and twenty thousand go hiking
yes
yes see i'm so excited i didn't expect
that catherine i thought i was gonna
have to swoop in
all y'all out there laughing y'all just
see y'all was like anthony don't do it
he said anthony said should you take
six months off to go hiking i was like
oh this is not gonna be good for
katherine
i do not like hiking but at the same
time
that's why we work so hard do what we
have to do so we can one day do what we
want to do
that's right live like no one else like
dave says so we can
live like no one else and so she's done
that part
go live now she would have said quit
working for the rest of her life kristy
i would've been like nah listen here's
here's my perspective that i'm bringing
to this too catherine as a mom of three
kids
go hiking sister go go hiking
if you have kids in your future lord
willing if that's part of your plan
now is the time now is the time to live
those dreams
before you got kids so go hiking and
that's chris that's as long as she's
saying 10 grand
you know what i'm saying 10 grand you
don't have a lot of needs out in the
woods ayo there's not a lot of things to
spend money
so what's she gonna do get rid of our
apartment and stuff back here too
no but i'm saying the 10 grand covering
the bills there's not a lot of
additional expenses it's not like we're
going to travel europe for six months
but that's going to be real expensive so
the woods are the woods are cheap so i i
love it catherine do it and when you do
call in and tell ao how it is maybe
we'll get him out in the woods get him